by now most of you seen the viral video
of the cat jumping on the Muslim leading
the Ramadan prayers for those of you who
haven't
let's go and take a look come back Drive
some benefits and then I got a free gift
for you at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
please
so what we're doing now is we've got
some volunteers helping us to get these
pews out with the hard work of Eddie
this is more than just a Masjid that's
being built this is more than just
another dawa Center yeah so we
transforming this from people worshiping
the creation to worshiping the Creator
Allah bless your efforts Eddie
the first thing I want to point out it's
quite a difference in the way the
mainstream media has portrayed the
Muslims nice for the mainstream media to
show the kind side here like you're
seeing here with the cat and one point
to note is that in Islam there are
people who actually literally going to
the Hell Fire for abusing animals and
granted Paradise for showing kindness to
animals such as cats and dogs I bet you
didn't know that now that's for Animals
imagine how much more kindness is
emphasized towards human beings now the
next question is what was he reciting in
the prayer the answer is he was reciting
the Quran the verbatim words of God
Almighty the Creator Allah and it's
amazing how Allah the almighty used the
cat to deliver this just like I'm doing
here with you right now if you didn't
know he was reciting Surah six of the
Quran chapter six of the Quran called an
Anam
Ayah or verse
147-149 in those verses Allah is talking
about those who took Partners alongside
with Allah and the tohi the pure
monotheism and I'd love for you to read
those verses in details and others that
came before and after that and that's
why I want you to hang around because
I'm going to give you this gift at the
end now the Quran has roughly about
three percent of it that deals with the
commands prohibitions punishments but
the majority of the Quran
teaches ethics the relationship between
God Almighty and his Creation With You
the purpose of life why you've been
created why you're here is it just about
sleep eat make some money and die are
you just like an animal or is there more
to you morality the Hereafter Paradise
Hellfire detailed descriptions the
history of previous Nations that pass
before us how to be successful in this
life and the next signs and proofs that
establish that indeed this Quran is from
the creator of the heavens and earth and
not man-made like other religions embryo
and the Quran cannot be based on
scientific knowledge in the seventh
seventh century
um
foreign
could not have known these facts about
human development in the 7th Century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century these facts could
only have been revealed to Muhammad by
the one no one who knows all about us
and all this in a book that was compiled
over a span of 23 years during the life
of the last and final message you sent
to mankind Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him it is indeed a
miracle for the one who approaches is
sincerely asking the creator of heavens
and earth for guidance examines the book
and I want to give it to you as a gift
the English translation you can go to
thedisho.com get your free copy from me
to you and if you have any other
questions any questions call this number
you want to know what Islam is does
Islam oppress women Jihad all of the
other terms that you've heard out there
that have been thrown out there and
you're confused you've been misled by
much of the hate propaganda a lot of the
hate provocateurs
a lot of the lies and misconceptions
that are out there you've been affected
by it but you've been led to us here so
go ahead and call
1-800-662-4752-18662
and ask your questions don't be shy and
we'll see you next time here on the dean
show don't forget to hit that
notification Bell subscribe if you
haven't already until then peace be with
you assalamualaikum
oh
[Music]
Allah
given a tour of the D Center yeah so we
transforming this from people worshiping
the creation to worshiping the Creator
Allah bless your efforts Eddie
how you doing brother
all right so you can see we're getting
to work and we need your support so go
ahead and help us to get this where it's
top notch inshallah